دخل اغلاق الحكومه بالولايات المتحده
الامريكيه حيز التنفيذ ازاء اخفاق
الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين في الكونجرس حل
خلافاتهم بشان قانون الرعايه الصحيه
المقدم من الرئيس باراك اوباما ويعتبر
اصابه الحكومه الفيدراليه بالشلل مكلفا
فقد بلغت تكلفه اغلاق مماثله جرت اواخر
عام 1995 ومطلع عام 1996 نحو 1.4 مليار
دولار وسيتا اكثر من 880 الف من موظفي
الحكومه الفيدراليه بالقرار لاجبارهم
جازات قصريه دون رواتب في وقت لن تتاثر
فيه مستحقات اعضاء الكونغرس البالغ عددهم
533 عضوا هذا واصبح في حكم المؤكد اغلاق
الحكومه مع اقرار مجلس النواب فجر
الثلاثاء صعوبه تجاوز رفض مجلس الشيوخ
لمشروع القانون المالي الجديد واعترض
اعضاء مجلس الشيوخ الديمقراطيين ب 54 صوتا
مقابل 46 على النص الذي من شانه ان يؤجل
البدء بتطبيق القانون الصحي للرئيس باراك
اوباما واعتبر هذا الاغلاق الثاني من نوعه
منذ 17 عاما من معركه موازنه اخرى جرت
وقائعها بين الرئيس الديمقراطي الاسبق بيل
كلينتون والكونغرس الذي كان يهيمن عليه
الجمهوريون واستمر النزاع بين الجانبين 21
يوما واظهرت استطلاعات الرئيس تيا
الامريكيين من الكونغرس وتراجع في شعبيته
وانتقاد
لاعضائه